valley a popular baby food manufacturer
announcing a major recall after several
infants became sick with bacterial
infections tonight we hear from a las
vegas family who says their child has
been ill for months because of this
madison kimbrough joins us from outside
summerlin er with the latest
this is where three-month-old baby
sameer had been admitted according to
his grandmother after he hadn't been
able to keep down his formula just this
past week several baby formula brands
were recalled including similac
alimentum and elacare formulas and the
food and drug administration received
four consumer complaints of bacterial
infections related to the formulas with
one death reported baby samir has been
experiencing weight loss as well as
fevers and utis and it wasn't until this
past week that his family shares that
they discovered the reason why his mom
and dad they've been so concerned since
day one of course this is their first
child
they are young parents you know
especially since we now know that every
single milk that he was on was included
in this recall this recall comes during
a major baby food shortage and it's
unclear as of now how many units the
recall affected but similac baby formula
is extremely popular within the u.s
samir is now recovering at home and we
plan on speaking to his parents later on
coming up at 11 p-m reporting near
summerlin parkway and town center drive
madison kimbrough live local now